we're gonna do it I think with Doudna
welcome to punch mug sports [ __ ] faces
hell yeah
ah here with my good good friends to my
favorite people in the world Tate
Fletcher and Steve Rannazzisi
punch-drunk regulars [ __ ] yeah
I apologize for a Tuesday everybody was
very upset with us like we have any
control over this but we promised we
would get one in and here we are and
thanks for coming back no problem I was
here on Tuesday reporting for duty but
you know you're kidding me technical
issues yeah that's what happens dude you
the fans thought they had it bad I know
I had to come here and just hang out
with a sorry and then I was talking to
re actually getting some stuff done and
Sam's like I got to go and just closed
his computer the middle of a good
conversation music I got just left I was
like all right Sam's at the punch bone
punch punch punch bone funny bone in now
the punch punch line Philadelphia yeah
all weekend and already is going to the
Yankee game hopefully there's another
fight do you I know you're a big fan
what do you think that fight first of
all I haven't seen a good fight like
that in a while one of the best baseball
fights we have had in a long time
what would be the second best baseball
fight I mean the Pedro Martinez when he
threw the old guy to the guy that was a
pretty good one that was years but that
you know what though the difference
between that one and this one I remember
a rod and one who's the catcher for the
Red Sox Varitek Varitek like they they
like they squared up right but there
were no punches yesterday Cabrera
squared up and and he kind of swung and
then they squared up and they fought but
you know Austin Roman had to catch his
gear on well I wonder what that is the
guy I don't want to fight on the
development of the tractor and he and
when when Cabrera swung
Romine ducked down and just grabbed and
brought him to the ground I was round
just kind of and then just started just
laying in like you know like like their
nose - no two versions of what was said
Roman said that he just said he's like
you know this isn't about you is like
are you saying something to me or
something cuz Romines brothers on the
tigris the catcher for the Yankees who
fought his brothers on the other team
so apparently
guess he was saying he had heard some
stuff about Cabrera and the umpire he
was complained to the umpire about
something and Cabrera jumped in and he
said hey this isn't about you Cabrera's
version is he said I'm not [ __ ]
talking to you so you know who knows
what's right but whatever it was that
was enough was like we're off yeah
that's that's a good excuse to fight for
yeah I mean I wasn't talking to you or
this wasn't about you that discernment
it's subtle it's subtle the insult yeah
I'm a guy getting hit in the last inning
though so they had taken some offense to
it it's thrown and then the Yankee got
through it the Detroit guy kind of like
in retaliation and then now that
thousand times bench like adults he
threw a ball yeah it's like a man you
throw it my guy guess what I thought
Cabrera was wrong
I thought Betances on the Yankees was
wrong he hit dudn't the next time in the
head like he says he didn't mean to hit
him in the head but I mean yeah on
purpose when you're throwing him is that
salt dude that's pretty bad five dives
like you're throwing it you know what I
mean he says he didn't mean to hit him
in the head he was going to hit on or to
hit him but not in the head yeah like
you're supposed to hit if you're gonna
hit someone you suppose a diamond like
this the back the thigh if you're aiming
to hit someone to send a metal door that
I what do you say you're supposed to
that's how you're trained well if you're
sending a message like sometimes I guess
you know it's like unspoken things it's
like the umph if you get if you're if
they if you hit a homerun your team and
then the next time up your best player
gets hit maybe first a second pitch on
the ass you know that was on purpose so
now your job as a pitcher no one has to
tell you is gonna go out there need to
defend your teammates and you're gonna
go hit somebody up okay you throw at us
I'm throwing down yeah there's a
protocol you throw it like I said it's
not yes for hitting a home run it's like
if you stare at it if you bow your boat
you know if you take a fence job Oh what
are the if you if I hit a home run
and I'm like admiring my [ __ ] yep or you
throw your bat and do one of these yeah
I can't celebrate my success or if I'm
rounding the big fans on who you are so
I marry bonds yes if you are some yasiel
puig does it all the time but people get
pissed so that I guess you might pay you
mate at risk yeah even me that's gonna
take yes a beating for you might take it
you might take it your next step back
yeah okay but for sure that
teamate I have that bad is gonna get it
also but if they take you out of the
game
in fact we gets pulled for defense for
whatever reason and he's already had all
run and show but like they all hit
somebody else maybe I love that the most
exciting part of all these sports is
fighting yeah yeah sure it's like
whether it's hockey or basketball or
baseball who thought that those nerds
and baseball would fight each other
that's crazy oh yeah I mean a lot of
baseball fights aren't it's almost like
yeah like I said a lot of squaring off
and a lot of jibber jabber but a lot of
guys at the bar get into the ground all
that like no come on a lot of that [ __ ]
these guys get up and they were a couple
like strawberries on people's faces and
stuff like you could tell like there are
actual contact yeah piles of people I
mean it's bench-clearing yeah people
were running from like the bulb that's a
poor boy out field hunting in they come
running waving stop the fight suit yeah
pitchers are like you know like they're
just itch they don't get to play that
much in there like you know sure there's
southern boys they're itching to [ __ ]
fight and they're just like let's go and
you got to see this dude sprinting out
of it he's like I'm let's do this let's
have some code kind of yeah we're gonna
defend our way em there's no [ __ ]
there's either I want some physical
contact some whatever happen yeah yeah
now is that Detroit right yeah yeah yeah
and then now then who would they play
today I have no idea because that was
the end of that series this is like the
last day game of the year for the like
they do it in summer they do one day
game a week I don't know yeah I mean I
don't know if they play Detroit for the
rest of the year I look it up but it's a
good one
it was a good like as far as those go
there's gonna be suspensions it's
probably gonna hurt the Yankees more
than anyone else because Gary Sanchez
jr. got into it later on
right so they if they suspend him and
Romine then we have no catcher so right
I mean it could be argued you don't
deserve a catcher at that point right
it'd be funny you should know that
without a catcher
yeah he's like constantly hitting him in
the chest pad the it's funny because in
like baseball and then somebody on
Twitter brought this up to me and I was
like that's actually a really good point
and baseball this fight was you know
a good fight for baseball yeah and
there's gonna be a lot of suspensions on
both sides of the ball
but in hockey it would be like alright
you go sit over there for three minutes
yeah I mean like you're expected to
fight in hockey well there's three I
think it's sort of gotten a little bit
better and not better but like it's
gotten pared down
tamer yes I think there used to be in
the 80s and 90s really they were like
they were goons there were guys on the
team who's like job it was to fight and
protect no no one Probert when they went
to yeah they went to Arizona to train
with Sugar Ray's boxing coach well yeah
and the hospice right that's like does a
Detroit Free Press story any offense
defense that they could possibly
contribute was all gravy you know it was
like a job was just to be out there to
people there was a little bit of like
that in the 80s in the NBA where people
do like because remember the Detroit
Pistons were so rough they would [ __ ]
lamb beer they would just clothesline
people really hard fouls and the Bulls
went out and got Charles Oakley and his
job was just to be the goon anybody
touches Jordan you thought you make him
pay for that you let them know you hard
foul him chosen I was gonna clothesline
you yeah it'd have to be like a
billionaire basketball player they've
got to be that's the scariest athlete if
you were gonna get beat up by an athlete
like every basketball player I just feel
like they're so athletic they're they're
strong cardio have good cardio they are
[ __ ] they're driven they're you know
and that's in their mind they're going
through that wall yeah and like like
those are huge huge athletic men there's
not other like a football player maybe
yeah a glazier trains and stuff like
that those guys like I would not want
ever I wouldn't want to fight a kill I'm
back I don't want a piece of nobody ya
know but yeah
badminton not basketball bruiser with
like a six foot seven reache when MMA
money gets to be basketball money do you
think that'll be the switch and though
cuz if you can shoot hoops like that and
you can make a hundred million dollars
who's not doing a bad source by a year
20 grand and 20 grand in the UFC it's
true
disparity is just just a touch of I mean
you even see that in the NFL now this is
all just talk about 2021 the NFL
striking all this collective Barty
bargaining agreement everybody in the
NFL and a lot of those specialized
players wide receivers cornerbacks
not the bigger you know 300-pound
linemen but those guys that were like oh
yeah I was a blue-chip basketball player
in high school they played basketball
baseball and football and they just went
to the NFL all of them are like man I
picked the wrong business
I see these NBA contracts coming out now
they're guaranteed and you know they
keep the collective bargaining agreement
keeps getting better for them they keep
winning everything more every time
absolutely more and more yeah so happen
anywhere but it's also it's different
it's a hard thing to to quantify because
there's so many people on an NFL roster
you know you got 53 guys 53 plus a
practice squad of 12 or 13 you know NBA
you have 12 people you got to pay so
probably it's like overall probably the
same amount of lump sum I just got to
pay 70 people instead of 12
marvelous but you also only have you
know 16 games versus 82 that's true to
make that that's not an absolutely great
point by the way did you completely us
do you know Atlanta put in the new
stadium they put a chick-fil-a in yep
you heard about that yeah mmmm and it's
closed on Sundays on Sundays when
[ __ ] football games happen yeah
awesome but I mean college game but yeah
Jesus College games concerts my rocks
WWF UFC - a [ __ ] 8 packed sold-out
Sunday every year going one chick-fil-a
hopefully 10 Wow a bowl oh that is it
there no no it's gonna be what's the
look at a third wheel as far as Jesus
goes like Jesus what doesn't look at
those Sunday's mayonnaise Laden chicken
breast sandwich on a delicious toasted
bun as a good thing I'm Sunday's Sundays
are for rest and family man so are they
mad at football also probably I don't
know gee I mean know somebody has you
work just not us because we're going to
heaven that kind of thing who us me you
know the people that you you know know
but I'm not gonna show got invited but
I'm not going oh I'm on the list but I'm
much I'm tired told him late I don't
know if I I don't even know if I want to
I'm not sure if I even want to hang out
with those people
well that's my point it's like everybody
that I know and that I've hung out with
it on I've enjoyed their company no no
those guys are going to heaven what are
they gonna have an area and your day
earlier and then Sunday hits you twice
it but it's really Monday do you go by
your Sunday or their Sunday and then
they don't have national religion in
China either you've seen a chick-fil-a
in China yeah if you were a chick-fil-a
owner perhaps I think they call this
ching hai's there it is [ __ ] filet
right guys wait wait
yeah I wrote that three days ago I
couldn't tape I saw the big Jumanji
picture of you with the rock there's a
little screenshot a dude sent me off the
trailer
how cool is he cool guy a cool rock yeah
everybody says that is awesome everybody
says he's just like a great guy he's one
of the nicest most genuine dudes and
he's got to be turned on all the time I
don't know I feel like the Dreaming turn
on all the time like turned on we gotta
be himself gotta be how you do it he's
got to be on threads you know I just
can't imagine how much headspace like
it's got to make you tired as [ __ ] to be
that guy that knowing kindly you don't
know man and you're out there you're
[ __ ] a 6-5 280-pound man that looks
like Dwayne Johnson with a smile that
blows up the room like a Tom Cruise
smile
yeah like holy [ __ ] he's I always I just
kind and gracious and all that there's
that in a whole new campaign he's doing
with Apple where it's like he can't do
it like the new story like he's watching
the news doing like three things and
it's like experts say the rock can't do
anything else or it can't do anymore
I'll show the and he's like on in space
yeah just I feel like he's constantly
has to be engaged with something to be a
like that's and then he just powers off
to go to sleep for like whatever
probably five hours how much of that is
him and how much of that do you think is
is the Machine around him the machine is
just like one or two guys though it's
like it's like he's got a security guys
really cool everybody's too you know
you're with somebody all the time you're
[ __ ] cool you I mean agents managers
studio but I mean
we need those people for those press
junkets when you're like I can't [ __ ]
picture of us and he posted it on
Instagram and uh and I'm superimposed
I'm photoshopped right - yeah bigger it
looks like my arm is as big as this
whole leg and he's a little bit bigger
than me like the picture I posted Albany
was a still frame yesterday on my
Instagram and he's about an inch taller
than me probably in he's probably 15 or
25 pounds heavier than me like he's a
big proper sized human yeah I mean and
like you're not I don't know I just kind
of felt like there's maybe proper size
to 10 look at me the regular stunt stunt
man guys that are there and I was maybe
the the ninth biggest one it's like
everybody is big on that you know and
that was the narrative for the show like
that's the that's the idea of
photoshopping I think that a little
bigger is like I'm fighting these
monsters that are here so what am i my
point is is that he controls the
narrative so well and there's nothing
thoughtless about what as far as the
machine goes it's like very very well
thought out mm-hmm yeah I mean he's a
he's a he's a juggernaut man welcome I
was surprised to see the list because I
thought Black is in there Kevin Hart
he's another one though I mean like I'm
sure the two of them hanging did you
notice Hayden ready that's watching this
another me Kevin Hart you'd give us the
sign of a [ __ ] real little you see he
was at the rams camp the other guys and
he dropped that ball yeah punt yeah I
couldn't feel the punt really I mean
yeah he's on my negative show you
shouldn't YouTube show and that's what
he was there doing that oh really huh
he's athletic I mean he's like you know
he works out he's probably like shame
can't like you know he's like 5 - Wow
probably you imagine even those guys
that are thrown those balls that there's
a lot that that's a velocity that you're
not used to engaging with like you know
what I mean this is a Ponting which was
kind of hard - it's like right so you
got to catch the ball coming out of
about 50 feet out of the air they have
this pretty [ __ ] huge I think it's
cool like what Kevin Hart does you say
he's making a youtube show what makes me
think about it's like and it's kind of
like this place or at the store we were
talking about earlier how
just got a creative idea here's a space
for it put your soil down and let it
grow well if that's the naughty show or
a fad whatever all that [ __ ] right and
and what he does he's gonna start a
YouTube it's literally what anybody at
all with an iPhone can do like if you
want content and you have a great idea
you can put it out there and it can get
traction and all and it's like and so I
my first thought is like how cool that
you just super rich you're incurring a
huge huge amount of income every year
and so you can do whatever you can have
a youtube show and going and feel filled
punts but literally anybody can do that
the same thing it's like the the the
difference in the quality of your life
and the quality of his life is maybe
just decimal points you know what I mean
but but but like the decimal points for
his rent his mortgages like all that
increase sure it's like at a certain
point a rib eye from a nice restaurant
is a rib eye from a nice restaurant
regardless of what the rest of it looks
like you know yeah the I'll freedom the
energy that he puts out there it's
incredible I mean he's another non-stop
guy he know when you put him in the
movie that were curtana money but he's
gonna be on every [ __ ] talk show
he'll be at every single like event
that's around there if it's around the
Superbowl he'll be at the Superbowl if
it's around you know the NBA and it's
not all tomorrow he's gonna be no he's
good he's gonna be turned on and he's
gonna be it'll be some sort of brandings
gonna be sponsored ship with the thing
so it all is it's a well built machine
but it takes a lot of energy and you
know guys like him those are like
superheroes to me I'm like it's not just
because of the size of the rock or the
lack of for Kevin Harper right the
ability to just keep that I wonder if
the rock could fit Kevin Hart into his
ass oh they were like Russian nesting
dolls you just opened up the rock and
you could find it definitely eat them
did yoga yeah yeah and just like really
opened up really relaxed and chakras
open what if he just like really relaxed
was meditating let his chakras open and
then Kevin Hart just comes out of his
ass what's up everybody and that's how
he came on stage for the next special
yeah like the rock on the rock reading a
paper just so slowly just like relaxing
yeah just literally just shits out Kevin
Hart onto the stage like we're gonna see
this on stage and then boom Kevin Hart
comes out that would be like
partner defense fundraiser for troops in
Iraq or something yeah they like many
fundraisers I bet they don't you don't
think they call them fund raisers yeah
yeah taxation pitch that to the rock
though yeah yeah sure I'll can you shove
Kevin Hart up your ass and then [ __ ] out
on stage I might pitch for muster
trading try this know you're gonna do
this publicly this is gonna be for a
fundraiser like one of those like that's
on every channel fundraiser hosted by
like you know I knew Jerry Lewis who is
the new Jerry Lewis by the way you know
who to probably be you is Tripoli's the
new Jerry low no it's the guy from The
Nerdist Oh Hardwick yeah I see Hardwick
Harbor the host it that's the kind of
thing he would rather see you I'd rather
see me - I'm not gonna lie I don't I
don't like you saying this Hardwick
dudes name I don't know just really not
sure because he always hosts things well
I would absolutely take you ah
how excited are we for the big fight
tomorrow pretty [ __ ] excited man I
think that there's so I are you excited
because before you were kind of like I
wish there were two months more or
another year I think that the reason
another year it's been since 2015 but
you look at you look at like what
happened with Josie Aldo mmm and that
was a year and a half of pressors
basically it bit blue connor up and it
also cost joe say that fight it would
gave Conor enough time to embed and
implant himself for his head they
announced that fight cuz there were
injuries there was the all surgeries I
think John got hurt yes I'm at four
stalled it again and again and that that
became a thing and so this is ultima and
then hosted in the result to was
catapulted to men because of this result
well I thought fight I was confident
Aldo was gonna win for sure so was Aldo
and I and the next one I thought and
then I was like counters real is [ __ ]
yeah it was no it's great agree now you
look at that and you look at the last
ten guys that Conor fought the hundredth
best boxer in the world would like those
guys up in a boxing match you know what
I mean like you know not a great boxer a
good journeyman fighter would outbox
every one of those guys and probably
knock them all out sure Conor's gonna
fight the very best so he kind of looks
great against all
these guys or whatever worries one at
least you know he didn't look great in
every fight but he fights this guy
that's the best in the world there's so
much like what happens after we got we
got Dana White as a character looking
like Don King like you come over your
promotion now you're in a boxing
promotion and you just got your arm
around your guy like are you guys do you
take a hundred million and you walk and
make your own promotion or are you
competing with UFC nuts or do you make
an old boxing approach what's going on
cuz Conor can for sure get fights after
this in boxing
he's my triple G goodbye mat real fight
Paulie Malignaggi exactly oh that's
what's probably gonna highlight it's
already started and so the only thing he
has to do is last all 12 rounds and not
get him back never fight and he can get
thirty million dollars again why would
ya you could get through fight Paulie
melon I think you will for a for a
million verses 30 50 100 euro bank and
forth he'll get a 30 million to fight
Paulie Malignaggi then someone will talk
[ __ ] in the UFC he'll go back in main
fight a UFC fight yes boy I don't know
his coin is up in the UFC after this
dude because he's now a household name
to all of us he always was but we're all
a sports fans and mixed martial arts
fans and UFC fans so we always knew
about Conor right ah now everybody's
girlfriends and wives know about Connors
my mom knows about kind of yeah yeah all
three of my mom's know about Conor you
know II mean so now for him to go to the
UFC that's gonna be front page news
again I've had people say oh you used to
fight and they go is that the kind of
thing that that Conor guy does they know
Conor you don't even know the sport they
just know this crazy Irishman yeah yeah
that's my point so whoever finds him
it's a payday I think also though like
what's Dana's play in this he's not
really he's not invested in the UFC
anymore he gets a paycheck from them
like where's all this go and then I'd
look at the fight itself Conor Knox guys
out he got hammers mm-hmm hard to hit
Mayweather
yes Mayweather doesn't knock anybody out
not and is it decades
not a long time sevens been a long time
yeah for you the last knockout was
against that guy when they had an
illegal headbutt or something and then
the guy like punched him that was the
last time he knocked somebody up that's
not legitimate I want Victor Ortiz I
think the picture
before that I think it was who's that
English guy the white ricky hatton yeah
he hadn't and that was about six or
seven years ago seen out and here's my
question what happens if first maybe
first finally bad second first second
round he McGregor pulls a ricky hatton
right drops his hands and just gets
caught with forty-year-old whatever's
left and then he will thank fresh power
right and goes down what does that do
for him next I mean he's out of boxing
is like sort of you get a box all the
time we saw what happens that him at all
when he now goes back to the UFC his
money is so low compared to plea in the
EOC it can only be higher I think even
if he loses this boxing match yeah I
mean there's a difference between
getting choked out by Nate Diaz and
having that sort of you know in the
sport in in a situation maybe you know
it's like I just kind of got caught up
in something like that but this I feel
like would affect him way worse than
that what do you think of the Nate Diaz
fight I mean that the one where he got
choked out like I have a feeling about
what happened there like everybody I
read every digits again the world's like
yo Jiu Jitsu but it's like boxing beat
Conor there and Conor decided he said I
wanna I'm gonna quit you could see him
he's here can he goes I'm gonna quit you
could almost see it all working I don't
want to get knocked off he shoots the
shittiest double leg ever yeah gets
taken down touched a couple times and
then gives us knack and when he turns
over like he quit right you're saying
instead of getting knocked out by
standing we made a choice he made a
choice overall we okay cuz we can get
out of MMA fights anyway you know we you
know we get to say in a bizarre by so
striking it's awesome boxing fight how
do you get put out you get knocked out
or you go the distance that's basically
it yeah or you can get you know stoppage
show right articulation so you're five
six eight rounds in your Conor
that old man he lives there he's happy
he's got all his breath this is what he
does for forever there's no adrenaline
for him maybe not for Conor either but I
would think Connor would be the one that
would get more tired in this fight
because it's a different kind of fight
really liked was 25 minutes versus 36
minutes I mean I know it sounds like a
big difference but is it really a big
difference or UFC guys are
are there is there wind good enough at
that level should aggregor level to be
able to just they would be able to go
there three more five round fight yeah
so we're talking about twenty nine
minutes or whatever it is right so like
you look at that's very similar but in
boxing we have an agreement a lot of
times if we're having a ten round fight
we're gonna agree to dance around and
move around we're not really gonna put
it out there and nonverbal agree you see
yes exactly all boxers do this almost
anyway about pitching you haven't
understood yep yeah
seventh eighth round now we're gonna
turn it on and [ __ ] go and move right
and that's and that's kind of the deal
and then they have that saying that like
you know a guy that's a KO guy he's
never gonna win a decision and the
decision fighters never gonna KO a guy
and you got a guy that's a KO guy in
conner and you got a guy that's a
decision guy yeah Boyd hunter president
and so like this is really interesting
just and that Connor is gonna go throw
it all out if he can't put him away in
four rounds he's gonna be a tired son of
a [ __ ] by seven eight rounds now what
does it look like and flash back again
to Connor
going holy [ __ ] Nate Diaz is gonna knock
me out or whatever he's making and he
shoots that double what does that look
like in a boxing match
now you're just there in the lights holy
dirt and you're taking holding all that
ahold it's not gonna be any stupid he's
not gonna lose that money but you can
you hold him because the difference
primarily with the boxing fighter and an
MMA fighter is footwork it all comes
down to footwork and a rudimentary boxer
has better footwork than most MMA
fighters either and we saw that with
Ronda Rousey and Holly Holmes it was
really articulated very well physically
we got to see what that looked like
somebody that we thought was a pretty
good striker Ronda was a pretty good
striker for MMA girls until she met
Holly and then [ __ ] Holly could move
around like she was transporting herself
like she would teleport behind her and
and make her fall down just by moving
and and we're gonna see that with Floyd
Floyd it's got the best footwork of
anybody yeah against the guy that it's
pretty girly in the UFC but he's also
good at baiting and so Connors whole
thing is like I'm gonna come down here
with Eddie Alvarez right hand low chin
low and I'm baiting them in he's got I
see him moving to throw that hand ding
and he hits him with that left and drops
him and that's his you can't beat Floyd
like waves too fast man and if you think
you're gonna pull those tricks that's a
[ __ ] long day for Conor it
really is because I don't think that
that stuff's gonna work no I don't think
you can bait Floyd because he just
Yuki's gonna get enough off to win the
fight and win almost every single round
and stick that chin behind that shoulder
and just sit there and you cannot get
him behind that shoulder I don't care
how long I waited because you'll be
sinking the thought will come in I could
body lock him and draw my quarry and
it's like I know house moving too but I
can get there with my other arm but I
had to hook him and grab him back but
you can't do that that's all wasted
thoughts because never thought doesn't
happen so he's thinking about all the
stuff that he could do but he can't do
and so he's going through the checklist
I could do this oh [ __ ] I can't do that
he's got to govern himself all the way
now you're not in the fight anymore yeah
remember when clubber Lang Gregg scrappy
when he's trying to get away about that
he just grabs him by like what is that
the hand yeah the glove and just throws
him back into the corner and starts to
work you can't do that and that's what's
going to his DNA he's gonna go I know
he's fast he's gonna move over there I
don't have time to get back but he might
slip mm back we might see a double leg
he can't do it he's gonna lose so he
loses like 90% of it if he gets
frustrated can you see him not to shoot
the double leg well that's what I'm
saying there was 90 percent of a hundred
and fifty million I still want papa does
that go into back into Floyd's that's
interesting - yeah because that's a gang
of money that's a house girl right now I
mean right I mean that's gotta be how
they do it now is you put that nice Crow
I guess they're somewhere that's real
money
yeah it's not like it's that money then
yeah sure Floyd get some of it I hear
they're probably loading him into trying
to make a move like that what this is a
tactic that he's worked on - I hear that
Floyd is going to come away with about
350 G's and Connor will come away with
around 150 to 180
kudos it's seven hundred million dollars
that's gonna make good for them I just
read on deadline which is the you know
the the industry trades they're almost
for it almost no one's going to be
filled almost a billion yeah dollars to
put it in perspective Damon to people
jay-z is worth 500 million yeah that's
his whole life's work a bunch of
platinum records movies clothing lines
deals with [ __ ] at like yeah but that
carry an Visnjic who just won that
Powerball can say [ __ ] you to both of
them I made more money this weekend and
both these
Walford I was so shocked that she even
showed her oh man realizes like one lady
53 years old she's like a medical person
there's a PI help you what's in it like
Visnjic or something like that I'm
proposing to you right now wit Kelly Wiz
need you need a mouthful of dick you
want me to bring anything from you
oh and gee ma notice nothing you know
you want herpes baby fax me she could
get that other place yeah with way less
money maybe much you want to be on
punch-drunk how about that that's a
quick come true right there yeah so
regular I'll just come to all things
comedy I mean in the middle I saw al
Madrigal yeah yep little stuff like you
drop it
yeah I would not even I'd be like my
name is Duncan Trussell no there's a way
you have to do it you don't you don't
you send like a lawyer
you never release your name first get it
she was all over the news one person to
bankrupt a lot of I love watching those
shows every catch like they'll see like
when the lottery heartbreaking for the
happy story in my heart yeah I bought
like all of Alphaeus cars or something
there's everybody says the same thing
there's no way I could blow through 400
million dollars but that phone never
stops ringing right you know and I
wouldn't be buying tiger you better you
better go Dave Chappelle and go to
Africa and just throw all your
electronics away for you live like this
figure out what's important to you right
you get a check but you got to reassess
that 450 million cash right nobody knows
who I am yeah I don't what do I want to
do from me and the people around me I'd
like to be things start a little thing
or to reality show put that money in the
bank and it 5% interest of 350 million
dollars means your great grandkids will
never have to work if they don't have to
but 350 now you get down to nickel and
dime it government's gonna take 49
percent no I'm saying that's it she gets
760 she went yeah 760 so she's probably
too clear around like for I did it for
43 I think it was yeah
man you know 450 like 450 she hurt I
mean she did stand at a 7-eleven and say
five [ __ ] numbers yeah that day - she
was like one of those people that went
like when I thought about going like
lights on the news at 5:00 idea timing
in position she did it she's just better
than us yeah I mean clearly now that
she's rich he's obviously a better
person than me um speaking of rich the
money's coming in now on Mayweather
those big bets that they expected at the
biggest at the mill all the money was
here Ultimo bet all the load bets people
trying to make money right now it was
like - 550 400 you almost had to put
like 600 to make a hundred it was like
12:01 a month ago right as crazy
yeah if you'd have bet a grin there on
Conor well that's what all the money
came in here but two grand today on
Mayweather you're covering your money no
matter what
no matter who wins you're [ __ ] doing
you're making money mm-hmm which is like
those people that have done that that
had that foresight but they're doing it
with a hundred thousand and two hundred
that like the million right now Nets you
like 189 189 thousand on a win for
Mayweather okay and what about what
about if you go the other way Conor you
throw a million Conor a million on Conor
oh I think really and a half million
yeah
well the funny thing is I watched I
don't know if you guys saw no one's done
that though no one's named numbers on
Conor Mayweather was on his MMA fans are
broke stirs well no just because a
million dollars you better be [ __ ]
sure no matter who you are and the
different most people those guys aren't
that those guys that bet a million
dollars that's like me betting $100
those guys are so wealthy it's just like
when you're around guys with money like
that it's not a I mean I've seen guys
lose that in poker and not be bummed out
about it go and eat breakfast they're
not even so yeah I was for some reason I
when I first read the article I was like
oh it's a million dollars really like
that I was expecting it to be like
someone put like ten million dollars on
Mayweather or like ten million on
McGregor or something like that where
you're like oh those are dude the
million is still a lot of money but you
like I believe that they placed about
with they do ten million on McGregor
that moves the line well there's people
that are we got a team of special
investigators that are looking into this
guy finding out who he is is he
connected somewhere they're [ __ ]
going on that's true I guess so nobody
really wants yeah
a million I guess doesn't send out red
flags but more than that probably starts
to go you're gonna get the whole mouth
what is this guy now [ __ ] yeah yeah
what's I lost five hundred dollars at a
blackjack table in Vegas I had to move I
had to come back here and surrender my
apartment what I want to know is where
did you get $500 yeah I didn't have
which reminds me I got some ideas I want
to ports booked in Ireland it's already
paid out on McGregor I'm on Mayweather
if you pay if you bet Mayweather they're
already paying out on them it's like
this famous sports book that pays out
I'm like but they also they've done it
before they paid out on like short sure
bets before they also paid out in
Hillary Clinton winning the presidency
Wow
yeah they pay it out like days before
that betting world is a whole world I
don't know anything about it is a great
world to be involved in and that's why
you should go to our friends bet dsi ah
this is the time to bet yeah we're
talking about this after the someone get
into some prop bets they have great prop
bets a bet
Betty I see a calm use the code punch 25
that gets you 25 free bucks to gamble
with throw it throw it up bunch of prop
bets take your free 25 bucks throw some
crazy prop bets on this fight we're
getting bats here's some great ones well
prop bet I don't even know that prop bet
you like not when we toss on a Super
Bowl you know you can bet on crazy
things ah right how many times trump
will tweet during this fight right over
8 or 7 so if Trump fires off 6 tweets
what color is the under what color is
the you know the MS McGregor where could
aware like what color short so that you
know it's something like here's the one
that I think is easiest to fix and I
would absolutely be fixing this
what will who's the guy that uh Leonard
LM you know I can't think of his goddamn
Dana why uh wrapper around so 42 rabbit
right little Wayne will little Wayne
have a shirt on or not what I want to
bow is will Mayweather
walk out with the Diaz brothers that
mine that could be one two that could be
one two will little Wayne have a shirt
on now about little Wayne's good budding
away and I pass if you're little Wayne
and I'm your buddy and I see that's a
prop that I got a bro the odds are
better for me if you do wear a shirt you
wear a shirt I'm throwing a hundred
grand on it right how can't they not how
could they police that and know that if
the winds
let you put a hundred grand on a
property you can't go that high okay
this yeah probably capped yeah and
really looked at for the scrutinizing I
think all the sudden you put a million
dollars on whether he's gonna have Gucci
or Prada shades on when he walks out yep
exactly I mean cuz that's completely hot
yeah so does prop pets probably have a
that's me just make an extra hundred
grand yeah I mean how many times Trump
will tweet during the fight whether
little uh knock down any knock downs if
Connor gets knocked down within the
first four rounds there's all kinds of
crazy prop bets will will Trump be upset
that Mayweather and McGregor are getting
all this attention and he'll tweet maybe
start a war just so he can get some
attention cuz they'll feel jealous he's
probably upset because in his eyes both
these people are immigrants are you
happy that you voted for him after
everything settle out here yeah yeah
not only did I not vote our guys in I
registered in the state I present mrs.
Italy I registered in the state of
Indiana sports family we went back to
the red state to vote against oh you did
as your you I thought you gotta say you
like some sort of no I was my order I'm
pouring my vote away here I had my
friend Lou go down there say you know
under nine difficulty my grandfather was
dead exactly yeah yeah yeah you own the
Trump campaign that that was a rough
time for you too and I did work on the
Trump campaign but it's only because I'm
such bad luck that I figured I'll [ __ ]
this up to nope it's the only thing I've
ever won I really he's a kudos to you
well I appreciate that I wish I would
have bet on that so go to bed TSI use
the code punch 25 that gets you've money
to bet over that DSi that's the best ad
that you've ever had done for you guys
probably a little more money I believe
if you go use our code if you then put
your own money in would that be punch 25
if you whatever money you invest in that
on top of the free 25 bucks they'll put
200 times on that 200 times the money
yep well 20 percent so if I put in you
know about 50 bucks yeah whatever money
bucks yeah if I put in 50 bucks awesome
yeah I mean I have 115 so go ahead use
that great time to bet not ten times by
the way whatever it is Pat two hundred
mean
ten times if I had a hundred would be
$1,000 exactly $1,000 for putting a
hundred in so Kimmel Rose here maybe
with his on Kimmel and first of all I
was shocked at how little his hands are
that's very fun would say how do you do
your hands hurt when it gets cold what
do you like Anton yeah your little hands
hurt your little man did I
how about woodbridge the hand he comes
by any so this is how savvy Mayweather
is he's already he's playing chess
because Connors like what is it I'm
gonna bait him into this like the way he
grabbed Josie's belt he goes near uh
it's racial off your little head you
know Annie called him a well-cut
what are you gonna do boy like like
you're like holy [ __ ] he's crossing
lines here but he's waiting he wants him
to get up because if he gets up [ __ ]
hands on me oh you want to be touched he
would have put him down right there and
slapped him Allah John Jones Cormier
when when he lit DC up on stage right
that's what he wanted I'm gonna dominate
him right now on the presser physically
dominant pick and he just sat there he
knew he knew he's like I'm not gonna get
up and get baited I'm not getting baited
to stand up but this ain't his first
rodeo by a longshot either but also may
I say this though I'm not gonna get I'd
say 90% of his I'm too smart to get up
and get baited but that other 10% is
like I really don't want to get up and
he's almost arriviste if he smacks me
where's that gonna go he's gonna beat me
up he's gonna dominant roles on a
[ __ ] dais table right now I don't
yep he's gonna get in whatever he can
get in yep but then again it's like yeah
he doesn't want a real fight no one
really right especially not before the
boxing exhibition that's a minute and a
half how long do you think a real fight
goes with these two Oh anyone a street
fight let's say octagon rules it's
whatever
however long Connor wants it to go yeah
just a minute if he wants it less than
that it can be yeah oh yeah less cuz I
mean he's he's gonna run around the ring
a little bit I mean he can literally if
I'm running at you like an airplane
please don't ever because there's no
defense he's got no wrestling defense
yes literally
like an airplane and there won't be
footwork that he can get out of that
wingspan it's turn and he'll grab him
and it will be just a matter of time how
long does it take for me to get from
here to there it's like that's the
answer it's seconds yeah yeah whip him
down and then just slap him he could
slap him until he breaks his jaw just
from slaps if you know I wouldn't know
how to get an armbar like I wouldn't
like if he just laid him down and grab
his arm yeah and he wanted me whether
was that's not humiliating no he was
there he brother meet spit in his mouth
slap him he'd do all that [ __ ] oh yeah
wiping yourself up why you beat yourself
up god I hate it when girls used to do
that to me what are we gonna periscope
this fight we're gonna was just gonna
scare us what you guys doing for it it's
my wife's 40th birthday and doesn't have
anything to divorce so I'm gonna have it
at my house because we're gonna be day
drinking all day vineyard and then we're
taking a bus back and then we're at be
in my house at 6:00 she's gonna get it
on does she knows she's gonna be ignored
that's after 6:00 yes yeah yeah but
before that it's all about her loss the
winery where are we gonna be I don't
know yeah over my house maybe I will
Tiana wants to watch it yeah sure
all right cool maybe one pop over do you
guys see how I was just left out of that
he know you around the Jason and he says
Jason you could come over
I never said anything everyone made eye
contact with me how this guy I
understand I look like this you don't
want me whatever that's cool that's cool
please anyway Steve's two adorable
little sons are just gonna look up at
you like oh my god how old are they
they're eight and five perfect yeah
they're the best dude oh yeah you're
great with kids too so I'm excited about
yeah so we'll figure it out maybe pop
over there maybe go you were invited the
Sookie so maybe with us on Kimmel
here's the crazy say when you talk about
bets here's a crazy one he says Kimmel's
like I'm actually thinking about putting
a bet on you myself and Mayweather says
I'll tell you what bet whatever you want
on me if I don't win I'll reimburse you
I'll give you your money back if I don't
win
and Kimmel girls are you seriously guys
I'm a hundred percent serious and then
shook his hand on it if I'm Jimmy Kimmel
I'm throwing twenty million dollars on
that throwing a hundred and fifty
million or whatever his game get my
hands gonna put down a hundred thousand
dollars and give it to charity either
way that's it'll that's what it'll be
for first yeah Kim I'm saying I'm yeah
camel okay I'm calling him oh I'm
calling man it's easy
I'm calling Kate Tahoe upper buddy
Hobart together D Ari I'm kidding
everybody fifty million I'm gonna be
like all right put 50 million on this
it's like your hedge fund I leveraged my
mom's health care for this let's win
yeah absolutely and I got plenty of moms
and then when mayweather lose it or
mayweather loses you just gonna go
you're gonna go to Mayweather and three
losses going oh man right if you real
rough loss sports book receipts it's all
in there you're gonna come back for
tomorrow
yeah but settle this time you guys in
the next hour you guys can get to this
yeah cash would be great that would be
great all good cash would be great no
champs time talking about carrying
around 50 million dollars Kimmel's like
what's the most amount of money you
carry run and he's like I want I can run
like 50 million dollars and Jimmy King
goes how heavy is 50 million dollars and
he's like oh the two of us couldn't
carry it together
she's got three guys that just each of
them has like eight million dollars on
him or something whatever I'm saying to
hit with him to write him in an
entourage of people they are
eight million dollars on them or
whatever it's that heaven what is four
times eight fifty four two numbers
that's you know I don't know because my
brain can't comprehend stops every I
know eight times he said he used to have
a Brinks truck
he'd have his own bring struts awesome
and he goes Bugatti
hey I saw it but I had to sell it he
goes cuz Kimmel goes you can't just go
to a bank and take out 50 million
dollars like they don't banks don't have
that much money on them I think I know
you got a special order it and then a
Brinks truck shows up at your house yeah
those up at the house that's a house and
he was actually I had to bring struck
for a while oh no no worries
to solitude he goes some other brother
who likes money I guess [ __ ] imagine
what does that even mean that yeah
there's no problem so probably he
probably owed what he thought you know
when you're that wealthy it's like you
have a number of what you think you're
gonna owe and then you know yeah it's
like there's more and it's like oh I've
expected to pay fifty million but I'd
have to pay so I'll pay another twenty
after I make this check right but then
you know hopefully did I thought I made
four hundred million last year turns out
after taxes on Lima 180 million so I'm
trying to lean these this year yeah like
that's what it is
Connor was actually suggesting and it
couldn't could be true that he had to
take this fight because of that like he
was on the fence about taking his fight
well here's realize you know owed
another twenty something million and
he's like let me go make a quick thing
about it like this just in the terms of
oh okay so say he doesn't take the fight
it's gonna take him maybe a year and
probably another four or five million
dollars in penalties to pay back the
twenty million dollars he owes because
you know investments in LF that money
takes time whatever else buildings all
that [ __ ] takes time he's gonna make a
lot of money but it takes time to come
in or I lace them up in three months and
I make three hundred fifty million and I
write a check and save myself four
million in tax fees you know you're
gonna get you're gonna get penalties and
all stuff so I sell two watches can you
mend his garage sale mostly I don't know
like how or you try to like yet do I
want to liquidate twenty million dollars
or whatever the exhales garage that's
twenty million
oh man he's got a couple but I think
also if you start to hear the motor cars
if you start to hear Floyd Mayweather's
laying off stuff to make twenty million
dollars liquid then that's probably
against what what was that ran off look
like though like I wore the same
athletic socks twice in a row and I
didn't throw away usually I just throw
them away after I wear them once well
like like I think it's Frick to get
twenty million he probably had to lay
off oh you'd have to tell the housetops
to like a house a property or something
I think that a guy with that he's got
such a well-developed
portfolio yeah that it's like you
wouldn't even know it's like oh he he
owned he own a golf course in Miami too
he just sold that like it's like [ __ ]
like true yeah zero on him at all I
think I think it's like what if it's
that I watch that all the money's in 45
cars
that's tough cuz you're not you gotta
sell 45 go son it's like to get 20
million bucks you gotta sell 15 cars
holy [ __ ] floyd mayweather selling 15
[ __ ] cars what's wrong with him oh he
was twenty million dollars that's not
good for the money Mayweather brand
right you know it's also not true
probably you know robably yeah and it's
also like what happens after this to
what would the big fight that we haven't
even spoken about is McGregor vs.
Mayweather - you know what that'll be
determined in about forty thirty hours
yeah about thirty five hours from now
it's gotta be know whether we want that
or not if it's somewhat competitive
what do you mean somewhat because look
here's a deal do people get a little box
all year long show of the talk and all
that stuff if it wasn't like if it was a
first-round knockout or it wasn't
competitive fight at all like how you
gonna buy into all that McGregor wins I
think we could be looking at a rematch
yeah if this thing is like a split
decision we could be looking at a
rematch if they both somehow magically
go down and it goes to a decision we
could be looking at a rematch here's the
thing you guys you're talking about it
in a fair play this isn't this is boxing
this ain't fair play you saw Pacquiao
with a dislocated shoulder or whatever
go and box him for all those rounds and
and it was basically a thrown fight it
was like setup choreographed we're gonna
do this anyway I know you're horrific ly
injured so let's make it look good like
that's the fight that they had before
like that they're not gonna do that and
make it we it's so easy to make a boxing
match look competitive this is strictly
about the money it's not to see you as a
better boxer we already know that answer
this is money that's a goddamn good
point yeah but this is entertainment and
yes I understand it and I think that if
if if Magritte if Mayweather I know
if Mayweather says to me they do it
twice in 16 months they're both they're
gonna clear a billion in 16 months if
they fight twice one makes six hundred
million dollars
one makes 900 million load my choices
wholly going into this fight and all of
my advisors and my bros and they're all
saying hey dude we're gonna smash him
knock him out and I'm gonna take a 150
out of this I'm gonna be great and after
this what I'll do as I forecast which
for sure Dana White is forecasting for
sure Connors forecasting they're looking
into the future and going so next year
I'll be able to parlay this 150 into
blah blah blah blah blah
or I could parlay it into 300 million
because I'm gonna fight the same guy
again because we just make the fight
look a certain way do you want to just
be billionaires Floyd let's be
billionaires well have will have three
fights you think that talk right [ __ ]
yes I bet they talk every night about
strategy for pressors and all that and
he's like hey how about I'm just killing
myself boxing and you're at the strip
club all the time okay 24 all-access is
is like that's all it shows I know that
he's all right I could tell there let
you watch all four of them no I didn't
watch them watch any of them no yeah I
watched the for this but there's a new
one today or something like that no
there was only four yeah but that's you
know so you look at like I can go back I
can make five million which is great
payday in the UFC or I can make thirty
million fighting triple G or whomever or
I can make hundreds of millions having a
trilogy fight with this one guy and
that's what their that's what we're on
the on the brink of we're on the on the
it's not to be competitive though yeah
you can make a Hanabi you and I can have
a fight and make it look competitive
Steve I'd like to see that you'd have to
be [ __ ] chicken parm
it's easy I think when you look at when
you look at like what was a neat me is
when you were fighting
call me canvas maximus is a coach that's
a day okay so natives in fact versus
chicken parm you can parm
but they to orient you look at the money
dude that and I just follow the money
I don't give a [ __ ] what it is you
people think the FDA won't poison you
yeah they will people think that big
farmers on your side it's not it's like
it's just money wherever the most money
is that's what's happening I I
understand I just feel like with these
guys and with with me
you can't turn down 300 mil you can't
turn off your competitive when you're in
the ring coming at someone and make no
qualms about it they both want to win I
think Nate Diaz can't turn it off if you
said hey Nate this second fight we want
to draw or we want you to lose so we can
have a trilogy fight that and and I
think he would he would almost maybe
maybe at first you might say you know
what dude a couple million neck look I
do that whatever and then he's in there
and even if he knows I'm gonna really
come up it's gonna change my family and
he gets clipped and he's gonna he sees
he's gonna kill him he's gonna [ __ ]
open up and he's gonna kill Conor
McGregor doesn't have that and I think
that McGregor is more measured I think
McGregor you saying he's more measure
doesn't have it because I feel like if
he he may come at him and how does it's
gonna be up to Mayweather to turn it off
to go
why is he why is he down right there
with his hands down I could knock him
out maybe I'll just I'll give him a jab
or I'll lay off of it a little bit is
that what you're saying like yeah keep
it competitive I'm not gonna finish him
instead of like the normal mistakes that
would end a fight or end a really a guy
you just kind of don't take those
opportunities up and what do you just
hope that like in the fourth round or
fifth round that something you don't
make a mistake yourself and he does the
same thing you could get accidentally
knocked out yeah yeah and you're
trusting that story years old
but you guys are both talking about you
built the rapport and you go hundreds of
million I guess if you've talked about
it when I can't imagine the two of them
every night I can't imagine well they
did go on a little tour together and I'd
here's what I noticed about whether they
were in different planes you know their
business owners always looked at the
money pictures of him and Rolls Royces
all his cars in Ireland I don't even
know how they get that many cars to that
Island but like it's [ __ ] crazy he is
money Mayweather of UFC
he's money McGregor that's that's who he
is of the UFC I've ever made do you
think that he was a blueprint oh he's
got his own suit line those are
businessmen do you think businessmen
aren't talking about their biggest
payday ever well I will play this
they're partners if you look at partners
in this business arrangement that's
happening tomorrow night look at that
world tour that they went on and if you
watched all four cities and they were at
it was extremely contentious first two
first two cities I mean they were really
going at it you get to the time they're
in London
together he's robbing him on his head
he's just a familiarity they did develop
this sort of thing which when you rub
his head I'm like man if he'd had done
that in [ __ ] la or Brooklyn or
wherever they were when they did that
yeah yeah there was a very they look
like we're gonna fight they look like
they're gonna fight in the first two
cities second two cities when they're in
Vegas and London O'Conner made it clear
this is boxing I'll kill you if I want
yeah with my hands there's zero you
could do when you got that iron find a
box with you when you had that I would
beat the brakes off you anytime I want
in a supermarket wherever and like I
think that price out he goes that is
true when Mayweather got that Irish flag
when they were maybe might have been in
the LA one that was Toronto
well Toronto that's where I was trundled
he got that Irish flag Mayweather did
and Connors like do something that flag
and I'm gonna [ __ ] you up boy yeah but
do you think that's real like now Tate
Scott he was sort of wiping his ass with
that flag or something [ __ ] him up
yeah you can cross this line gonna bend
all that he's out there I bet I wouldn't
be surprised if it was came out that one
of Floyd's assistants was like yeah
Connor brought the flag over and told us
we should do this and let's do this for
tomorrow's present I would not be
surprised with like what I said with the
Pacquiao deal we already saw that box I
mean we've seen a thousand examples of
boxing being fixed of boxing being
predetermined in some regard thousand
you know what I mean without that
example I'm very compact that the
highest-paid fight in the world that's
ever happened is it gonna be amid some
[ __ ] no that's by the way I had no
idea that the Nevada Athletic Commission
gets 8% really do you know that I'm
surprised it's that low eight percent
that's crazy is that you you think
that's high someone was saying and
making an argument that this shouldn't
even be allowed like they stack
shouldn't like it's a sanctioning body
should be a government body not
something that you you're already paying
taxes they already paying governmental
taxes so is this double taxation so I'm
saying like people were arguing that
this fight should've been sanctioned
like this guy should not been allowed
about 50 million dollars oh well
whatever 8% because it's supposed to
come up through the ranks as a real box
I guess I mean it's like I get you know
it's sort of like a celebrity like if
you know kind of look if Rogan said he
wanted to go in and fight Floyd
Mayweather and it all got together and
they got to the point like would you
would you like what sanction it like I
don't know like how does that work like
he's there's no professional record he's
you know I'm saying it's like yeah not
like you they wouldn't just let anyone
in there I guess it is now I don't see
it that way but everything's marketing
8% does make a big difference
that'll tilt to like yes or no an eight
percent of two hundred millions not that
all right but eight percent of seven
hundred million is a lot of [ __ ]
money a lot of money that's what I'm
saying literally anything can happen we
could watch anything happen Trump's the
president you guys like I don't know how
much more I can say this is the first
good thing that's happened in America
since jumping in bread oh yeah that was
cool too
well Trump brought that for us yeah
somebody I think was an article in The
New Yorker was uh right before the day
of the Eclipse there's an article in The
New Yorker that said Trump says son
equally to blame for the Eclipse that's
good it's one of those we wish you said
yourself uh guys if you want to go to
the Conor McGregor fight there's some
tickets available really I believe so I
believe they've had a hard time selling
tickets for this to live to actually
being there yep Gino's going because uh
because uh but you know what you can do
go to see geek go to see geek use the
code punch drunk and that get you twenty
bucks off your $10,000 get a pretty good
ticket for like four grand probably
somewhere probably probably yeah go to
see Kiki use the code punch trunk
anything you want to go to any concerts
you want to go to a friend of mine Chuck
and Sarah my Canadian friends and
congratulations on their pregnancy are
coming to America to hang out and he's a
big Broncos fan and want to take his
wife and a future child to her first NFL
game and he goes dude I was I went to
Ticketmaster and I was like [ __ ]
prices were so high
went to see fees use the code and he's
like it was a hundred bucks cheaper
hundred bucks cheaper why because they
have all those stupid fees yeah the
price you see is a price you get you're
like they're this $100 ticket then you
get a bill it's 180 bucks like what
these are Canadians
yeah he's American she's Canadian
they live up in Canada though that's how
we shouldn't give him discounts hey he's
American so they're in they gotta go
he's American very uncomfortable
where's the kid born uh not born yet
[ __ ] they're pregnant I think she's
doing like maybe February or something
it'll be born like an white kid oh yeah
well I mean he'll be very surprised if
it isn't if it isn't he's expecting it
to be white she might have some secrets
she doesn't want to share yet she might
be rolling the dice she should actually
also go to bed TSI and throw some money
down on this thing being white like a
prop prop that what color would Chuck of
Sarah's kid be just used prop bet
improper very well done very well yeah
so guys go to see geek use the code
punch or get your twenty bucks off any
ticket you want to go to a college
football coming up Pro Football coming
up you want to go to a preseason game
any concerts any plays anything you ever
want to do Beyonce go to see geek I
guarantee you that right now
well he is if he is now you get jay-z
tickets in we do some I wonder if I
wonder she's sure no problem Q I'll put
it put in the call what celebrities
would you like to watch [ __ ] they be
high on the list
Oh jay-z on say yeah because you know
they're putting in work tired at this
point I don't know man 44 45 years old
what but he'd been [ __ ] like that
like an Olympian since he is what 22
what am I chopped liver over here on
crossing puss I want to see the chick
from Modern Family and that Joe
Manganiello guy [ __ ] oh wow okay why was
that - no is it bad that I remembered
his name another he's a guy that is he's
a big dude - was in he was the wolf in
True Blood
True Blood yeah okay and his wife is a
woman from Modern Family Sofia Vergara
Sofia Vergara
thank you yeah yeah I like to see again
if I get a little surprised you remember
his name and I don't know either sounds
like you really want to watch him [ __ ]
do you want do you want to watch just
those two or do you want to see a
threesome oh I can I throw someone else
in there yeah oh it's gonna be another
dude what I already missed
oh yeah you could throw a girl in I
guess not - I'll make it a dude I want
to make it imma stick to my original
thought and make it a dude the rock I'm
not gonna let society push no no I want
a dude in there no no throw somebody for
a goof in there like that guy that
mini-me guys know I'm a trained Knight
the dude from Seinfeld and Jurassic no
perfect writer I was a guy Walker night
that helped me out gave me some
cigarettes one time when I was locked up
really nice fella oh really real true
named Walker night and Walker now Thank
You Walker that's a good hey ni ght
solid to me yeah yeah ni te I grant yeah
um what uh would you like to see [ __ ]
it's not it's not very politically
correct I mean yeah hey guys there's a
punch oh yeah wait a second down here so
what I'm hearing I go to is is always
like your sister and Ari my sister nari
always just that fresh sauce Baldwin you
got there I know I wouldn't I wouldn't
be sat on it well I feel like her
character would get built you know she'd
be emboldened yeah she would definitely
take it on the chin if you know what I'm
saying
I'm not sure I'm talking about calm
where's Ari Ari's not wearing a condom
I'm sure of that wherever he is or is
that the Economist Ari Shaffir
speaking of Yankees the suspensions came
down oh we got what do we got we're
seven games Gary Sanchez four so Cabrera
seven games
Sanchez Sanchez four and that's it there
are those the only people that took time
that's that's the headline anyway okay
yeah all right
maybe not in Austin Romine take out you
go almost got baited into a classic one
which I encourage everybody and thank
you to everybody for [ __ ] on Bobby
Lee you guys all did a great job I want
to thank all the punch-drunk fans what
happened with Bobby well Bobby Lee was
gonna show up and then he'd Bobby needed
up
yeah this is gonna be the guest and said
he was gonna be here and then I called
him the day before
sois mail obviously Bobby Lee's
voicemail full he's one of those guys up
inbox full he can't even leave him a
message I get it
doesn't text back Jardine's the same way
he's a and then just doesn't show up so
I told everybody hey just tweet it Bobby
Lee just make it rain on him hey you
were great on punch-drunk today thanks
for taking the time out and a lot of
people said really funny tweets good
they really rained on him pretty hard a
piece of [ __ ] that Bobby oh wow really
well you know what he did to me what got
my hopes all up he was like you know
what you could come on you can do five
minutes on stage with me at The Improv
in Ontario never heard never heard from
bump into him all the time I'm not a
dick I'm not gonna go and be like hey
dude I'm not gonna hold your feet to the
fire but I'm like I'm around man you see
me nothing ya see now he doesn't even
say hi to me he just looks down and
walks away oh yeah I remember there was
a time where he would always you know
the Comedy Store there's always like
some dumb game that's going on oh I
already beat him up that one time people
just les yeux this new [ __ ] if you're
ever reading something [ __ ] if you ever
reading something at the Comedy Store
there was a game going on people just
slap it out of your hand
yep and it was called you ain't reading
nothing turned into you ain't eaten
nothing where if you had like a slice of
pizza nothing
god damn it you got your Joe's pizza on
the floor you're so pissed duck and I
had this theory we wanted to get so rich
there were gonna be like you ain't
texting nobody and just break somebody's
phone and just break them off cash hey
go bro get stuff any phones a grand for
your mini computers oh yeah exactly but
then there was the you were right it's
the [ __ ] ball slap was going oh the
other one was the worst the sack tap
because it was always like you're
talking to a girl and someone comes
around the corner and boom flicks your
balls and just folds you and it was
always at the worst time dude are you
get it to me at my special taping I said
I was out good night everyone the Wilbur
theater right yeah but for me I am good
thank you guys so much hands in the air
hands in the air legs separated I he
getting bigger there I notes from behind
he came snuck up like right behind me he
just came up and like boom from behind
moving my two legs and buckled me and in
the audience eruption he stands up and
yeah what a hero he is for that it's a
greatest item maybe he thought of that
was great huh I expected more like no
pants on no pants
Bolling you imagine doing that the wrong
guy like little that little Josh or
somebody that's down there now and he
sees he's oh yeah we're fun were playing
the dick-slap game
buhbuh buhbuh buh and then [ __ ] like
big Josh the war master or something is
there and all of a sudden he gets
accidentally slapped and then somebody
gets murdered that's what happened
because Bobby got me like two different
times like within five or six minutes
and the first one I was like ah he got
me got me then five minutes later comes
around the corner Zing's me again and I
just looked at him I go you're gonna get
it for that that you're you just made
the list he and this is what ended that
game what about a week later he's
sitting there talking to somebody and I
just kind of come around the corner like
lower my level and just straight on
straight left punch right
I didn't flick his balls I was just like
all right straight on dick ball punch
he's on the ground for about six seven
minutes that game is over nobody no more
cause I'm gonna get you bro that was
remember remembered what you just did
cuz I'll give you one free one but don't
just keep punching me in the balls all
night long I won't miss your pain for
one yeah unless I'm unless I
specifically that's like the guy but on
the he only twisters always hated that
is sure way for you to get beat up go
ahead and do that yeah like there's
there's not even anything you could say
you you gotta expect to get [ __ ] up if
you do that [ __ ] yeah dude Crowell used
to pinch like a little like you know
like like it was a hot day on set one
time he just pinches me I go don't ever
[ __ ] do that to me again
yeah just like really fun my god it's
like really making me mad mom used to
like when she was upset like grab the
back your honor and I remember being
like just [ __ ] tell me what you want
and I don't do I hate that I did too
yeah that pension will piss me off
pinching yeah so put titty twist pinch
all that all that [ __ ] I might [ __ ] you
why do you want to make my life just hug
me it's a it's nice to see you there you
go come on man I'm trying to be a nice
man be nice to me Warren
don't thank you - so are you Steve ah do
you guys still do the league fantasy
league are you guys still together once
it's a once the show is done it was the
show ended because you guys were always
in a league together
did one for the years that we were on
the show yeah yeah and so once the show
ended you guys had a disagreement of
like hey man then it's over
disband with the friends but we're not
making money - yeah we never really did
it
together are they gonna be at your house
tomorrow no they're not yeah are you
guys all still keep up and yeah closer
to dinner every like couple months
that's cool but uh yeah we never were
into the league our league when we were
on like we're doing the show all day
long it's like the last we want to do is
go home into your computer and like talk
[ __ ] to each other
are you a fantasy guy I like it yeah
mm-hmm but I mean I wasn't the show took
a lot out of it like I would be as into
it as probably you guys are yeah but it
was like a lot of it for seven years and
it just sort of I enjoy watching the
inventory yeah I mean yes yeah people
soon like last night I was on stage the
comi star walked up on setting it Mike
out this guy's like who drafted the
first front row and I was like I bet
nobody does that so much yeah I give it
a lot just from red zone and from people
that know me from this show and know I
work on red zone I get that a lot of on
Twitter and on you know DMS and like
dude but this audience was like did it
was it we're the Comedy Store in LA so
it's like the some people didn't hear
what he said I don't understand I put
like now I have to address what's going
on sure sure sure
so it's obligatory to have to talk about
fantasy which I get I and I enjoy doing
it but I I'm like now watching one game
have you watched one off room 104 yet
yeah
duplicate me too I was the one that I
was a wasn't totally like loved but I
loved the first one I loved mm-hmm with
those two kids the twins yeah I actually
googled them and looked at him up
because I was like was that one kid or
was it - because I figured it was twins
no no I'm sure his twin it was twenty
with those they've got a lot of [ __ ]
yeah they're like those guys were of the
Olsen twin because having twins is for
that industry is beneficial because you
can work five hours and then have the
other one work five hours right working
as long as they regularly line cut in
half the amount of lines they need to
know well yeah I mean a six-year-old a
lot of lines but also it's like they're
great though we're good we're really
good real good so it's you know it's a
benefit I did I'll be in an episode
later on I played there's an episode
where this
to MMA fighter females well the episode
is about her I'll get into the room I
play her manager how many episodes
didn't even know how many there maybe
I'd like 8 or 10 OHP I think I picked up
for a second season yesterday oh good
great cuz I really liked it
well mark was just like I've seen it
it's on HBO it's kinda like a Twilight
Zone it's about it's a whole app there's
nose cast so that every episode is in
this hotel room this room like what's up
happens in this one yeah it's for it so
like a black mirror type situation for
me to watch well some of them are scary
funny some of them are thought
promotional yeah so it's like there's
every episode it's just like I knew
people check into that room that first
one was great that little kid the best
line I was like vennett because that
other kid comes out and then he goes
back in and then the good kid comes back
out and he goes What did he say did he
get yeah yeah it's creepy what do I get
you and you're like what the [ __ ] does
that mean
my buddy sent me the funniest text now
this guy everybody has like those
classic friends not even like re but a
guy that just always not like he's a
dumb guy he's been acted he's been a
little million things he's just one of
those like kind of like meathead guys
but he always has the funniest [ __ ] one
time before he totally sure he used to
be the door guy at the saddle ranch for
years and years and years so he was
dripping and puss big guy oh and he's a
good-looking guy too and he's the kind
of guy that before I worked at the
redzone we would be working we would be
always at your buddy's house would have
six TVs set up and we just have all day
to order food and smoke pot all day and
watch football day he shows up like late
so now it's like the afternoon games
we've been together for like four hours
oh [ __ ] I just remembered I have my 11th
threesome last night why all of us go
you had your you walk in with that so
yeah you walk in with the gas shoe at 11
and it says 11 so he's the kind of guy
that every time he says something you
have there's a list of questions after
he'll say something so we're the saddle
ranch and he goes let me ask you
something Teebs
is it gay if a girl wants to put a
strap-on and [ __ ] you in the ass
I go first I mean she's behind you
there's not really like an intimate
thing and they're shaped like dicks it's
you're getting [ __ ] from it's kind of
leaning gay huh huh well is it game she
wants to put a finger in your ass or
after the dildo I think if it's just a
finger in the ass that's different kind
of curiosity exploratory I don't think
that says gay
how many fingers have you had in your
ass and he goes at one time okay that
wasn't my original question but it is
now yeah one time so he's texted me
doing that because I told him watch out
Joe how many fingers oh I don't remember
how many you got he was he was also the
same guy that remember Jay Leno man on
the street they used to do he starts
texting all of us it is again this is
1516 years ago everybody check out
little Mon little tonight and all of us
like this [ __ ] doing on Leno
okay sure [ __ ] man on the street here
comes [ __ ] Frank walking on the
street and raw like yes this is gonna be
great
shows him I only remember a few of them
Leaning Tower of Pisa mm-hmm what's this
called ah tilting cheesing he gestured
he goes back and forth between tilting
towers built in town I'm teasing tower
PluralEyes is both of them settled on
still towers grand canyon man-made or
natural hmm that's a good one Jay that's
a good one and Jay Leno goes enhanced it
a little bit that's it thanks for giving
that life [ __ ] every single one of them
was [ __ ] hilarious that he was on and
so he I told him watch the show we were
talking my game of Thrones and I go dude
check out this one before I think you
like it and then he text me back it goes
kid and it was just text but I just read
it in his voice you know he goes tell
you what bro if I'm old girl and in
episode 1 because if I'm old girl I'm at
least opening up the door talking about
it's hot in here
oh yeah if I'm old girl I'm at least
that's creepy kid that [ __ ] was creepy
if I'm old girl I'm at least open up the
door talking about it's hot here [ __ ]
man I love that guy I really saw
wonderful wonderful about the last
episode of Game of Thrones coming up
yeah I know I just started watching this
season that like seven or eight episodes
already welcome you've never seen it
before and now you just start and play
with my plan to catch up did you catch
up already catch up no no need I got a
brain here's what I'm doing you dumb
[ __ ] yeah you tell me you call me
whatever you want
great are you kidding me so she says to
me I go game my wife no my wife we got a
huge game of thrones watched every
episode of course so she goes it's
coming back I go I go I'm gonna start
watching it she was well you got to go
back if I go I'm not watching all these
why I walked watched all of them yeah
like religious but yeah she's like yeah
I'm going to are you gonna watch I go no
what am i I go I get the premise I know
I understand television and the
narrative thought okay I've been on
sitcoms yeah I get it yeah so I watched
the first episode of the season right
can you tell us the rest of this as
Brody I wa I I watched the first episode
of the season and I got it mad at his
brother yeah they're brothers the
brother [ __ ] the sister sure obviously
there's family problems families have
good times families have bad times
my sister beat me with keys that hurt
the most because she was a janitor yeah
so I get like I understand what the
problem it like these people don't like
each other there's a war going it's it's
Sopranos it's [ __ ] Boardwalk Empire
it's bad a lot for the territories so I
look when when they started talking
about the minutiae Lee you did this to
me because of that guy alright fine I
don't get all the backstory but the
[ __ ] dragons come out and start
breathing fire and you don't need to
know you don't to watch you came in 100
hours to know that that's [ __ ] awesome
yeah well we because those first time
that's ever
in drag Nucky I told my wife ago I go
hey that was coming I don't think
they're gonna kill that [ __ ] drag and
that creepy guy she was what the drag I
got and it's useful in thousands of
hours watching the show and I knew that
was gonna happen before you did I just
don't understand how you the first time
I watched it it was when there's a scene
when Khaleesi yeah holding Randy by the
way cuz I respect women it's not worth
it that's why I'm not going back that
stuff was one my mole was nude anyway
she walks in with eggs into the fighter
yeah my where she would burn alive and
then that hatches the Dragons that was
the first thing I watched I thought this
is gay mm-hmm [ __ ] dress whatever
[ __ ] children and then I watched it
from the beginning and I'm like there's
for sure dragons in the world like
that's we just they're smarter than us
and they're somewhere else right now I
don't know how you suspend your
disbelief enough to just stop you've got
a really creative mind first of all you
know the opening tells you everything
that shows you the map of where everyone
lives yeah so already longest inside
that opening are a hundred times it
always a hands on where's Westeros and
they across the big knows what's going
on
I'll tell you right now those [ __ ]
White Walkers out there are some bad
[ __ ] what about a white Walker
polar bear what is that thing that's
like the thing from lost yeah it is like
the thing for law that's a show I've
never seen is that we're seeing it
watches twice yeah they've well here's a
deal
I like drop the ball to end yes and
imagine imagine the joy you feel right
now for your the love of Game of Thrones
and then having it like at the end like
to the dirt and then it's like a little
boy wraps it up and it was like a toy he
just puts in his pocket and what the
[ __ ] with me like that whole like right
you're like yeah then again no hashtag
aliens we're out yeah thanks for the
season yeah somebody just wakes up and
we're dreams is puzzle away and that was
it that was the end of st. elsewhere
right if the whole the whole show was a
an autistic child's snow globe what yeah
that's how st. elsewhere ended really
the hospital show the hospital show shut
up
with Denzel Washington yeah Zell was
insane outs what yeah
I was like too late and what are you 64
how do you remember I remember that oh
no I don't remember that at all
yeah Hill Street Blues I remember that
was before that hell yeah I just read a
the names of these shows okay sure sure
sure I don't have any idea that I mean I
knew it was in a hospital was it in
Chicago I don't always say always or
remember that what are you guys on day
night are we coming over your house on
Sunday to that or won't son I got to do
a benefit for not only in the Comedy
Store who Paulie oh you do it in some
day she got real quick yeah I'm doing a
benefit for at the Comedy Store on
Sunday I don't know what it's for what
time what time will that be eight
o'clock
it's Pauly Shores running a benefit for
children of the night I don't that's not
it that sounds creepy it's weird but
yeah but it's for the children of the
night body night the nightwalkers bro
you know he thinks my name is Teebs
Sid let me have a cigarette bro let me
get one for my baby always wants two
cigarettes one for him and one for
whatever daddy wag is talking to I'll
plug some stuff while you're looking
here I got no October five six seven
Portland going back to Portland sweet
helium comedy club October somebody just
told me last night that there is a a
vegan strip club in Portland there's
more strip club in Portland and if you
have every place has like a bar and like
one Google steaks I remember going to a
strip club in Portland that had the bomb
steaks and they're like $4 and they were
awesome yeah they all serve food too
yeah but a vegan one I thought that's
those just fat gooey girls in there like
probably I don't even go to that one
it's a good thing we're watching the
fight at your house because I am doing
the rent is easy Comedy Festival and
heavy-metal drummer fest of all we way
every night starting at 1:00 a.m. all of
September brought to you by me it Danish
and O'Neill I don't think that's a good
well because I'm gonna be home all all
September I don't want that going on in
my house did you guys did you book the
band's already at they're better booked
it's mostly drummers though like one
band has 11 drummers nine guitar players
we have a koto
you get the guy from the bar
but it's gonna be pretty epic oh yeah
animals gonna be there animal from them
up and then I am doing a big benefit for
the troops the Isis troops that should
be good I'm at the broken mic then I'm
at night of a thousand party it's the
wrong side of history yeah there's a way
to change that then I'll be at the Dutch
oven that's where you have your
residency right at the Dutch oven yeah
yeah so and problem I other dates you
can follow me on Grindr now uh John
Jones so what happened I know what does
he not nobody's taking or I I have no
idea I like what the fallouts it was an
oral steroid it wasn't masking drugs
it was a straight-up oral steroid not
injected into him there's no I don't
know if he thinks somebody like X his
only excuse could be like nah man
somebody laced my cocaine I didn't lose
that fall on
I mean falls on John they made it they
made it fall on GATT nutrition last time
didn't they days they said then the same
thing didn't they say well that's who
sponsors them but gap but GATT is not
it's like that's such a lie they what
they what they end up saying like
Anderson said it - there you go
well the pills that these are made in
there's other pills that are made it so
that they make deca in this also or
whatever the other pills are and they
make him in the same as the dick pills
and I took the dick pills and there was
residual how much [ __ ] residual is
that like to be bioavailable in your
body that alters you so that you piss
hot that's ridiculous
like you can't you're making ten
thousand a hundred thousand hover me
pills you're making it a thing and
there's enough leftover powder of your
steroids that you were doing in the same
machine sir I mean I how do i suspend my
disbelief enough to follow the chain of
event that says that you're not cheating
yeah you can believe dragons but not
that right exactly I got you know I mean
this obviously he's got a fire who his
nutrition people are right I mean or
sadder decision or yeah but that's
number one no number one is I out
blaming people and you take [ __ ]
counter to your goddamn life when you're
going when you're training for it like a
regular MMA fight how much how many how
many but it's not a teens and
I'm like how many things are you taking
every day when I take when I train for
an MMA fighter him sure
short teams yeah you tell us what you
take and then I last ate besides Nick
yeah yeah um load come Cisco hey yeah
like you know it's like guys would take
multivitamins and be think that they're
on top of their nutrition it's like
dudes at the highest level of support
didn't know very much about nutrition
and they still probably don't so now
you've got power lifters or you've got
different guys that are a drug Laden
community yeah that are trying to push
your nutrition for your best gains or
whatever so you can have a big deadlift
which maybe isn't translating to kickin
guys in the head anyway but like
nobody's there like when he gets out of
the ring and he's like okay here's your
mid-morning pills and like that's okay
so it's not like that unconsciously
putting stuff in the Oh paddy that's
what I'm wondering it's like three times
a day I come over and they gave me like
a shake and some pills and I take that
and I mean maybe that happens I don't
know but at a certain point if you're my
guy that's giving me pills
I'm vetting you I'm finding out what
those are and I'm like exactly I'm gonna
kill you because this is our cost me my
livelihood and divorce my life yeah and
I'm the only thing that's made you
popular go back to your dark little
[ __ ] gym then forever and never come
like it's like it becomes like that it's
like you gotta have accountability you
ain't fighting and that's the thing you
miss hot and all this all these times
like you know you're gonna piss out
again I don't get it I don't know but I
also think it all should be legal I
think it's foolish I think we're talking
about a childish thing this Daniel
Cormier now do you look at him like a
champion is he guilty he's gonna wear
that's his belt of shame I know I mean
he's gonna Walker was before he can't be
saying this is like because the guy that
beat the brakes off via the scarlet L
just gave it to you like enjoy that
ballot I mean he's you only ever lost to
him though
he'll never put that belt on I don't
think I mean I wouldn't you say though
if the guy that you prop that beat you
only two times you ever lost it's now
never gonna probably fight again when
you say like well then you know no one's
ever beat me on the champion the
headline today like there's no belt at
all that belt evaporates and they have
to have other fights to make that viable
yeah you know what I mean - yeah - get
the potency back in that belt do you
think John Jones is the best guy to ever
walk do you think he'll ever fight again
in the UFC for sure I mean that's the
thing is going to be two years
arbitrary weird thing I don't know about
that well yet one they got old is he now
got Brock let's just turn 30
yeah there's a coach who doesn't big two
years the UFC dictates who gets popped
right like when Brock came they gave him
a pass through qual he doesn't have to
do an on season urine analysis because
it's such short notice that he's gonna
fight mark hunt and he pisses hot you
know what I mean it's like but he's not
expected not to piss hot you know like
and and they you sod it doesn't give
that to the state of letting a
commission they give it to the UFC the
result you sada is owned and paid for by
the UFC it's not that Nevada so it they
get to control the narrative yeah so
it's whatever they want you know that
really so they're not they're not
they're not a separate sanction o non
affiliation man here's why I think you
developers best hot and I've just been
like yeah absolutely the Olympics all
the time and they don't [ __ ] know you
sure about you know for sure and they
cover it up for sure why wouldn't they
cover up the Jon Jones thing I don't
know I mean I too many people know I
don't know all the stuff yeah this is
just my supposition I I don't I don't
really I haven't been in the room when
they're going are we gonna let this one
odor not let this one out but I mean
it's clear that that happens with the
choices that they've made both other
guys and and you can't have it sometimes
be okay you can't have it it's okay if
it's offseason it's like it and you
can't kick [ __ ] Nate Diaz out or Nick
Diaz for smoking pot like it's like all
that [ __ ] is ridiculous and at the end
of the day when we get epigenetic
enhancements that where everybody can
just be [ __ ] and whatever physical
physical specimen you want to be
everybody that's in the arena is gonna
be a better condition than its two guys
fighting if we keep up the
ridiculousness we either want don't you
want performance-enhancing do you want
guys untrain well the problem with that
is the moment that is is that it's
either All or Nothing because you have
people to go okay I am NOT going to use
all these different supplements or
steroids or use them for recovery or any
sort of thing like that because it's
against the rules and then they are the
people that do do that so it's not at a
fair playground
so it's either it is a fair probably
ground I'm saying you make it you make
it yeah but there are people if I say
this is the rule you can't do this
are people that don't do it aren't their
normal limits within a certain like if
you were if you if you're a doctor who's
gonna prescribe like I'm gonna make Tate
have the best possible performance in
this fight mm-hmm everything's legal
right you give you a little HGH a little
bit of this a little bit of that not
that not that I'm gonna hurt you I'm
just gonna get you to the point where
isn't that I don't they have the ability
to regulate what those levels are and if
you were to make everything legal why
wouldn't you do that and then say piss
after and your levels have to be under
all of these numbers almost like a DUI
like or no yes Drive
we know you build break point 0.07 yeah
yeah so it's like if you test over a
point just anything over this number
will hurt your liver or hurt your brain
now to hurt your whatever we don't make
sense right now we want to pretend that
things don't exist that are in play and
that exists everywhere always saying
that it's a hard argument but the point
they always make is like you don't want
to tell kids like you have to do this to
be able to get kids right in their asses
[ __ ] them you guys will take your
[ __ ] kids and you send them to Sunday
school to get [ __ ] by the priest
you'll send them back to the same priest
after there's a court proceeding that
says he's been [ __ ] your kids you're
like I don't know Jesus you know like
it's [ __ ] ridiculous this thing we
got cigarettes legal we got [ __ ]
drunk driving that is basically
sanctioned by the states that are I mean
in New Mexico anyway you got you I know
a guy who's got 13 drunk Driving's he
killed four kids he's still driving
today like it's like [ __ ] ridiculous
that we're gonna say yeah this small
little microcosm of athletes that's
what's really gonna sour the brains of
kids how [ __ ] stupid are you people
it's [ __ ] ridiculous that's the
dumbest argument I've ever heard and
also you're the same Constitution dude I
just do it for my kids I could have
really shined in life but I had these
kids you know and I'm just doing it for
that it's like quit blaming your [ __ ]
kids for everything have responsibility
love your kids enough to teach them some
[ __ ] things and stop it that's silly
I worry about the people then I'm I
don't wanna use kids but like the kids
that are trying to make it and just
aren't good enough yeah and they're
gonna be there I'm feeling should I give
them participation trophy too then that
they make no I'm saying but then they
take extra and they're like they're like
well I need more and more you know being
dumb is bad for elite or like your life
being dumb is not
is not shined upon in Darwin's world and
that self-leveling I'm not trying to
save all the dummies you can't catch all
the lemmings before they jump I
understand it I'm just saying is it
there's a thing rather have them does it
argument mean to say like I would like
to say like I never you always have an
excuse thing like I wasn't good enough
because I didn't have the right drugs or
whatever right now with that when you
have drug testing and says like you
weren't good enough because you did more
and good enough you know well you'd
weren't the best athlete so John Jones
on no drugs mm-hmm it's probably beats
me ten times out of ten if I'm [ __ ]
on drugs I'm on all the drugs I don't
hit a baseball out of the park like
Barry Bonds hmm it does it's not a
deciding factor Tran I don't think that
I think that for average citizen Joe
then it looks like dude that's the thing
if he'd had done this no man it's not
that much of a difference it'll help you
I think the biggest thing that steroids
or drugs will do in the sport is it
elongate a man who already has a
infinitely short career I think the
career in the UFC right now is a a year
and a half it's like 18 months or
something it's [ __ ] small sure and
you can elongate that because you'll be
able to not be injured as much you can
recover better cause elongate a career
so you can maybe have a couple more
years with that if if you're smart about
it the other thing but it's not like
well it made my punches way I don't
believe in that I believe it changes
your mindset and I think it can be
damaging to athletes if you're Superman
and now we're tested in now where I'm
Lois Lane going in there I'm not really
a Superman or whatever the deal is and I
think that has big mental factors that
don't get talked about really because I
think guys get broken I think we saw
that with pride to athletes with Heath
Herring and and Nogueira those those
guys came back they looked horrible in
the UFC when they came back but not all
their confidence bond Vanderlei all
their confidence was shook because
they're not on drugs anymore and then I
found out all we can take drugs here too
and we saw and now we've seen the
varying results of all that as they've
tightened up the the reins on that but
the reason that they tighten the reins
on that is because there's class-action
lawsuits going hey UFC you knew that
Steve was taking drugs and he knocked me
out and you weren't taking care of me
because you don't even test these guys
well [ __ ] when that stuff started to
murmur and they're like we're gonna be
big and we're gonna start selling this
company soon was it Mark Hunt doing that
well didn't did he want part of Brock's
but that was after the sale right yeah
but like I was upset and
so what happened before the sale was
this thing was happening there liked to
posture us to sell this we're gonna have
to put things in place to act like we
care about that got it which they don't
say way and so they just started testing
stuff so that when we go to court we go
hey dude we did due diligence what else
could we have done we we had guys we put
on suspension look at John Jones he
always took he always took a lick for
every time that he pissed on I mean that
becomes the conversation really instead
of like I want this to be for the
betterment or to not hurt kids or dreams
[ __ ] you kids you're not doing [ __ ]
anyway you know I mean either you're
gonna come up and you're gonna shine or
you're not
drugs aren't a part of it I've fought
guys on steroids before it ain't a big
deal but what happens most the time with
guys on steroids because we know so
little about it because it's illegal and
because everybody has this this this
cloth they cast over it about cheating
so nobody talks about it it's untested
guys run out of gas all the guys that I
knew that would train that we're like
big steroid guys [ __ ] good man good
let's go cuz after the first round
you're [ __ ] like you've got no gas
tank at all now that's just in practice
then you put it into a game day
you gotta weigh something you're
normally a 185 er but now you can't get
underneath 190 for some reason huh
that's weird I wonder what he's taking
that's holding all that extra weight you
know now you really [ __ ] and now
you're mentally [ __ ] up too it's like
there's a whole bunch it's not a simple
thing like he took steroids so he's
better and that's why he's won that's a
that's an immature argument you know
what I mean and I and I do believe [ __ ]
we want big v8 we I mean we like Trump
the this big blowhard and president like
we in America we like all that big [ __ ]
give me some titties oh yeah implant
whatever in your ass baby I love all
that will you like WWE we're guys are
just on steroids and in tights that's
all we really know about it but we love
it we don't want this in baseball what
are the chances one of those guys pisses
I mean I don't think Mayweather piss is
positive but McGregor I don't think I
doubt either one neither one of them
have that in them they're not that I
don't know I mean I may if Mayweather
was ever going to play with you wasn't
only on tests probably he's 40 years old
you know he's probably on tests he likes
he likes testosterone okay he likes to
be rich and [ __ ] a lot you know and it's
probably more of a section
enhancement for him than it is for for
anything oh hang on
get on testosterone Oh what I mean yeah
and so like be a man for once it seems
silly to me this this whole time what
makes it I understand also why does it
what do you do with the money then what
do you do how do you how do you sell
this fight for 60 bucks and then say
like thanks for watching and I'm not
really by the way the results don't
really matter and the other guy I'm so
sick of that happening and then what
happens with Bonnie what about Brock
lesner
and John Jones fully juiced let's see
that have you ever seen buster not juice
no do we all know that everyone seen Jon
Jones now juice not in a while you know
yeah probably not and I don't think it
matters and also on the other side of it
am I more offended by Jon Jones being
juiced or DC having a spare tire and
being floppy and overweight
that's the highest representation of the
sport how embarrassed are you why are
you not embarrassed man look like a
goddamn champion then he's always you
know maybe if you worked harder then
that would be you know what I mean it's
like it becomes that kind of thing it's
like what face are you is that a worse
face on the sport
Jon Jones doing that and going this is
just I live in America and this is
[ __ ] what it is and like whatever and
everything's available to me do you
think they released it this week because
it's getting swallowed up by this thing
I mean he did I did see him on
SportsCenter I think y'all taking a
couple questions about it and he's like
it's a black guy for this and that buddy
can always pivot to like how exciting
this is yeah you know the NFL always
does that the way yeah they'll really
sort of like you know I mean Bo if this
fight wasn't happening this week and
John Jones got suspended that would be a
big [ __ ] they'll be the biggest story
story in fighting warts yeah you know
one of them but I mean let's and let's
face it all those guys that are there
like DC's a tremendous athlete he's
[ __ ] one of the very best guys in the
world at what he does
and he's a great orator he's got like I
like all of that everybody knows this
and so now is this just positioning to
pump up another fight or to say sour
grapes because the thing is that I know
as a man I walk into a ring there's guys
I got knocked out by a guy got stopped
by him not completely to finish but like
they stopped the fight and they shoulda
and I got clipped and it's a guy that
was not better than me I'll say that a
hundred times and I was better than him
in wrestling I was better at striking I
was better at everywhere everywhere we
just got clipped and a guy says to me
afterwards would come out
and he goes there's a lot of talk nine
times out of 10 dude nine times nine 100
talk man do you beat that dudes ass like
that and I and my ego wants to go yeah
yeah yeah and then I go then my [ __ ]
the mind that I love that keeps me
honest spoke to me and I wish that mine
spoke to those guys that [ __ ] about all
that [ __ ] and the thing is 100 percent
of the time that I met that guy in
combat he knocked me out that's the only
truth there is yeah there's not like if
I'd have done it this way I'd have been
able to make be more successful or that
no [ __ ] there's only what
happened yeah and I have to look at
reality I can't look at these fantasy
football leagues and all that [ __ ]
that goes on it's like it's just what's
real you know what I mean and that's
that's the realest thing about fighting
that I loved is because we can find out
you know jiu-jitsu is rad
oh really are you a black belt in X Y or
Z cool is that better than the [ __ ] I
got cool let's see we can find out in
like three minutes on the mat easy
nobody even has to get hurt and I'll
know you know I mean it it's like that's
that's the thing is like that's a
proving ground of truth that cage and
what happens in there like once I enter
there with another guy it's me and him
and that's it I'm not thinking about
like did he eat a full breakfast is he
hydrated
did he take [ __ ] does he think I'm
pretty ain't part of the conversation
does he want to see beyond test this
guy's on test imagine that he's on test
he's on coke he's on PCP and he's coming
at you go across the cage yeah what do
you get if you're here we're real tango
now hey I want to test oh wow this guy
because I'm not even really maybe saying
I know maybe having it all full-bore
illegal isn't the way but there's so
much [ __ ] in there I'm like can we
just stop the [ __ ] and just let it
all be legal even if that hurts us a
little bit at first because the fact is
you piss test us before we fight yeah
yeah it's time you didn't stop the fight
you guys so you knew he pissed hot and
you still put me in a cage with him how
about you [ __ ] yourself that rule how
long does it take you what is it an hour
is it really I don't know like what's
the technology for that how hard is it
to find metabolites in your blood or
piss not very [ __ ] hard I know I
think it seems like it takes time
apparently totally it takes a couple
weeks a month I mean that's right that's
ridiculous thing they should you should
wait while the commentators are talking
to doing that like their their walkouts
right and then the results come out like
both fighters are coming what handcuffs
on a guy and if it's not then you get to
vote like do we still want to see these
guys fight you do Emperor style yeah
that'd be rad [ __ ] yeah it's like one
like they just randomly pick it they go
DC you still want to get some yeah he's
a little bring him on I take what's
going on a caveman caveman coffee we're
just over there killing it yeah what do
you guys got done we uh I don't know
that we haven't seen new per se but
we've got a reformulated vanilla MCT
that's [ __ ] pretty nice and we got
we're all out through New York and Whole
Foods and stuff like that and we're just
looking at distribution more and talking
to there's it's weird cuz I'm learning
about I'm learning it's it's a lesson
for me mostly cuz I'm talking to all
these VC guys now and and I don't know
how to have that conversation really and
so just kind of learning as I go through
these waters but is is where we're at
and technologically I'm looking at doing
a couple things that are pretty fun with
it and that I don't know I look at
whatever I'm doing isn't forever mm-hmm
even your mom and it's just a stepping
stone of learn minor is learning how to
take it to the next thing right so like
whatever I did before is just informing
me more of how to be better at the thing
I do next time and that's right
that's so there's a bunch of cool kind I
feel like I'm in school all the time
what caveman coffee yeah go to caveman
Coffee Co calm guys and get what you
want you can use a good punch trunk that
gave 15% off of whatever you want I
personally love the night rose you know
I hung out with you and giardini other
day no offense to him because he would
absolutely rip my head off and just [ __ ]
down my neck just as a goof it's pretty
scary yeah there's a little shorter than
I thought he's gonna be I mean it's cuz
I'm so do style tall you are but I was
like oh wow he's much good and then he
shook my hand I'm like ah he's one of
the strongest people ever he looks hot
just [ __ ] looks like it so I was
talking in for a while and then he goes
how do you like it coffee I go he goes
he just like the night shows don't you I
go yeah and then he starts give me all
this scientific [ __ ] [ __ ] a nerd
he really was I mean he was really
excited to talk about it I'm like I just
I don't know he's on shameless
he's filming this
shameless right now that's really
favorites bro yeah so he picked he
booked a recurring role on that he's in
this others I thought me a my sister
grew up we always just say that that's
our about our is that right yeah well
you know I was done I may have told this
on this show before but my dad and my
and hit my uncle they used to drive
around like the south side and like
right by you know each acog Oh ham and
Gary are on there they drive around a
pickup truck if they saw an unruly
looking character on a bicycle they
would yell that's my bike and if they
jumped off the bike and ran it would
just better still really looking
character someone who didn't deserve
that bicycle like that guy on his
bicycle anybody black or anybody white
trash looking that's what I was thinking
you know that's that was their game they
would yell that's my bike if they jumped
off and ran
they would just reseal the bike and if
they didn't they would just keep on
driving like it was no big deal and then
it would sell like six bikes at the end
of the day I mean if anybody's ever been
like maybe don't notice but like if you
live in a neighborhood like that and
it's common you'll see a dude that's a
six for rugged gangbanger looking do
diba and he's riding and he's riding a
little girl's bike something like that
okay and that's everywhere everywhere
that nobody has their own bike awesome
man it's my bike punk yeah okay J is
doing that and then we got to show
godless coming out me and him and cowboy
did which is like a cowboy show where
that'll be [ __ ] on I just thought was
Ian um Logan yep yeah so I'm in there
okay yeah got him people Oh to the back
and the fact yeah I'm like that it was a
quick little thing I'm like Dan that
looks like him
yeah man so that's going on we got we
got big we at the end of the month in
Texas in Dallas we've got a two-year on
the 31st we've got a two-year
anniversary of clutch Dallas and then I
some having a big party then and then at
the end of September we have it's a five
year of concrete cowboy Dallas and so
lots of Chicago one going those are
going great - man yeah that's wicked and
they're looking at doing some more
things out there so that's all pretty
exciting and what else pirate life radio
just doing that and then trying to get
an another job so weird thing being in
this business like you're continually
unemployed yeah everybody's like I love
that life cool you could just go tell
jokes and all that it's like I always
say that I'm unemployed
every every Monday today we're
unemployed oh yeah I'm unemployed till I
get on stage tonight I mean it's like
you having that having your show yeah
must have given you so much solace as
far as having a family and going okay it
no it can be okay because as an artist
that's out there just trying to do a
damn thing it's like day-to-day look I
don't know that I can feed myself let
alone have somebody that I take care of
red Red John starts from our first
rehearsals tomorrow and I'm like let's
do it yep 19 weeks of me having [ __ ]
consistent money yeah yeah you know yep
that's a real thing that psyche that
goes into being a creative because I
mean that's all beautiful and ethereal
and everything else but I got to put gas
in the car and 11 expensive town to live
in I know you look at house to be like
hey that's a nice little two and a half
million dollar house is a $80,000 house
in my hometown mm-hmm you know I mean my
buddy's a house in Pensacola
and he goes what do you pay for your
part of it I have a small studio he goes
what do you pay in that place and I told
him I pay and he goes dude that's my
mortgage I have four bedroom and a
swimming pool
yeah that's my mortgage I have a room my
apartments as big as this room
practically kitchen in the bathroom he
write like on my phone a lot so if I
land in a city that haven't been in
before all this little incident hotel
and do I and it's sometimes the Perret
like the your margins of what you are
looking for the houses like are left
over from LA and I was like I'll have
him there and like Columbus Ohio and see
what you get in Columbus oh yeah yeah I
mean it's like it would be like wooden
Mayweather would live in absolutely yeah
yeah yeah yeah in my hometown forget it
is a seven million dollar house in Los
Angeles yeah I mean it's five six
bedroom and pool all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
did you guys watch you watch Ozarks I
just start I just finished it episode 7
I'm off to love it
I watched 7 nothing to do with the show
ok ok explain to me one part about then
I'm not understanding about money
laundering so save it fight like you
said 5 million bucks right sure how is
he putting money into the shirt like say
was gonna build the church right and
how would you then get that money so you
put a million dollars into building the
church right is it so that it only
really cost a hundred grand but you
invoice like five hundred he's my
carpenter how much is it gonna cost you
to frame this fifty bucks
okay I'm gonna write it up for five
hundred dollars and I'm gonna give you
fifty bucks but then but then the part
that I don't get is that jason has to
claim that that he's been paid five
dollars so I have to pay his taxes on
that - I would say how much yes so maybe
that's why he said they get fifty
percent of it doesn't come back but it
was a putting money into buildings was a
little confusing to me I was like how do
you then really it explains lampshade
stores in LA to me I'm like how's this
[ __ ] just selling I never bought
a lampshade in my life I know how did it
no heroin that's hot that's why the
lampshade stores that been there 30
years you'd have to clean money
yeah one thing where you look at like
the brothers a guy who's buying rugs
you're buying that many rugs that you
can keep a [ __ ] busy on Melrose stop
my wife bought a lot of rugs when we
bought our house hardwood floor and then
she goes out and I'm like what are you
five thousand dollars worth of rugs I'm
like we could have had carpet we could
have go to a house with [ __ ] carpet
good of [ __ ] party's over
um uh guys thank you guys so much for
being on the show thanks everybody for
listening one last plug that we got for
all things comedy is it's our good
friends at it's just fruit is that what
it's called
that what that's it fruit calm
that's it fruit calm grapefruit bars
good tasting big flavor for four grams
of that's funny veggie protein and they
have veggies they have veggie as well I
know we had the it's just fruit on here
before but this time they also have
veggie ones man it's good it's healthy
under a hundred under hundred calories
vegetables fruits all the things that
you need go to that's it fruit comm
backslash punch drunk and that would
like it to have to change their name do
you can't be [ __ ] saying that's just
fruit oh we got vegetables too well oh
man that's actually what they started
with that's
what they started with that name and the
fruits going good they just want to
remind everybody hey they have a veggie
one suits good for the kids it's not so
full of sugar everybody loves it even
the fight nannies no suggestion box can
I go to their website and I think you're
doing it right now okay verbal
suggestion I think you're arguing as
always thank you guys so much
Tuesday's seminar will be back and we
will announce all of the people that are
in our fantasy league I will give a
quick spoiler alert
one person is in everybody submitted
wonderful things a guy is gonna slam his
dick in a dictionary I tell them as long
as it's on the penis page of the
dictionary that'll be fine you're
probably and everybody suggested a lot
of crazy things of why they want to get
in but the one guy that I picked myself
that I love the most his email subject
just said football and the body of the
email just said thanks you're in sir
everybody else paragraph after paragraph
after paragraph one guy just as subject
football thank save or whatever is Becca
Davis I can beat that guy that guy I
imagine he is ESL if anybody else isn't
so thank you guys so much
go check out Sammy CRE whenever you can
see but watch his special double
negative on Netflix both of them are
hilarious I'm very proud of my buddy and
go see Sam in Philly you guys thank you
guys so much I love you guys but I want
to also if people could tweet Bobbili
and talk about how you broke my heart
yeah be good but show me why it's got
his heart broken thanks man suck it